there are three real indicators that
biden lost this debate his tell is when
he says come on
he said come on 1 000 times last night
it's all gonna be over soon
come on learning to live with it come on
come on
come on come on folks come on come on
come on is lecturing me on social
security and medicare
come on that is how you know he's losing
otherwise you know he's losing he
actually starts glancing at his watch in
the middle of the debate
he's like when is this over i really
have to pay when is this over there he
was
good look there from slow joe okay so
frank lunds
had a focus group last night that focus
group described
the various candidates according to
frank luntz's focus group
the words to describe trump were
controlled reserved poised
con artist and surprisingly presidential
the words to describe biden were vague
unspecific elusive defensive and
grandfatherly
okay i feel like a lot of that is
accurate and those are not words that
really bear in joe biden's favor
okay so now finally we reached the
debate the stakes were quite high
the debate opened with talk about covid
so
this is always a topic that is going to
be a problem for trump
simply because no matter who's president
of the united states if a bunch of
people die while you're presidents of
the united states people tend to blame
you
if people die it's the president's fault
if people don't die it's to the
president's credit
it's this bizarre sort of weird
fixation on who is the president of the
united states though the president has
magic wanting to just make everything
better at a moment's notice
2.2 million people modeled out were
expected to die
it's a worldwide pandemic it's all over
the world you see the spikes in europe
and many other places right now
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic
i guess they would call it some people
could say it was a cure
but uh i was in for a short period of
time and i got better very fast or i
wouldn't be here tonight
it will go away and as i say we're
rounding the turn we're rounding the
corner it's going away
okay so that sort of language is what
joe biden has historically pounced on so
joe biden has been telling one lie
on covet it's a lie the media wish to
reflect and that is that if
donald trump had handled this wildly
differently then
hundreds of thousands of people would be
alive today hundreds of thousands of
people if you got an empty chair at your
table that is donald
trump's fault the dog crap the carpet
that's donald trump's fault and the
narrative is it's all doom and gloom
of course the moment that biden is
elected it won't be doom and gloom
anymore with the idea but here was joe
biden
overtly suggesting that donald trump is
responsible for every american who died
of cove which is just crazy i mean i'm
sorry it's a crazy
immoral statement it is immoral to
suggest this 220 000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
if we just wore these masks the
president's own advisors have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
so this is the same fellow told you this
is going to end by easter last time this
is the same fellow who told you that
don't worry we're going to end this by
the summer we're about to go into a dark
winter
a dark winter and he has no clear plan
and there's no prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year okay so if if trump ends up
winning the election
in a week and a half one big reason is
going to be because people don't want
the doom and gloom
they don't want to hear the doom and
gloom that is doom and gloom stuff there
from joe biden
and so so joe biden is preaching doom
and gloom
right trump is not preaching doom and
gloom and so this is where i think trump
started to make hey he started to turn
the tide i thought about 15 minutes into
this discussion
when he started talking about lockdown
policy
so believe it or not trump is the
candidate of optimism on covet
it is biden who is the candidate of
pessimism doom and gloom
eternal nuclear winter we're learning to
live with it we have no choice we can't
lock ourselves up in a basement
like joe does he has the he has the
ability to lock himself up i don't know
he's obviously made a lot of money
someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that i caught
it
i learned a lot i learned a lot great
doctors great hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nation we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have a nation
and of course the cdc has said young
people can get sick with covet 19 and
can pass it
people are learning to die with it you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over to try to touch their
out of habit where their wife or husband
was is gone
learning to live with it come on we're
dying with it
because he's never said he said it's
dangerous when's the last time is it
really dangerous still
are we dangerous you tell the people
it's dangerous now what should they do
about the danger
and you say i take no responsibility
okay i don't know what the hell biden is
talking about at the end there but that
is the contrast in vision
right trump's saying correctly we have
to learn to live with it which by the
way is the exact same thing european
leaders are saying emmanuel macron has
said this boris johnson has said this
everyone in europe
is saying the exact same thing joe biden
is saying we can't learn to live with it
we have to
we're learning to die with it right it's
all like apocalyptic doom saying
from joe biden over and over and over
and then he went on to say we're going
to lose another 200 000 people
by the end of the winter right okay
that's
i mean if you're trying to scare the
living crap out of people so they'll
vote for you good luck
i mean if i think there may be a secret
backlash to this right if the polls are
wrong i'm not saying the polls are wrong
because i tend to be much more of a poll
believer than most other people
but if the polls are wrong it's because
they're underestimating
the amount that americans are sick and
tired of hearing from democrats how many
americans
are going to die at trump's hands and
that we can never go back to regular
life and that we will be wearing masks
for the rest of eternity and that our
businesses will be locked
down if there is a brewing sort of under
uh brewing underground against lockdown
culture
it's gonna manifest in in the election
but you haven't ruled out more shutdowns
well no okay no i haven't no i haven't
ruled out more shutdowns
and trump immediately comes back at him
and again this is good from trump he
says all he does is talk about shutdowns
it's literally all the guy does all day
long he just talks about shutdowns
democrats keep talking about shutdowns
we have to open everything is what trump
says that may be a vision that americans
are going to embrace particularly if you
have kids
okay there are a lot of people out there
who are not on board with the lockdown
culture here was trump fighting back
against biden on this
all he does is talk about shutdowns but
forget about him
democrats democrats all they're shut
down so tight
and they're dying we're not going to
shut down and we have to open our
schools
people are losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it often the cure
cannot be worse
than the problem itself and that's
what's happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country if
one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
okay so that was again i thought that
the conversation would turn quickly from
trump's rhetoric to what's going to
happen from here on in that conversation
certainly
benefits trump then we move to trump's
second line of attack
and the second line of attack for trump
is that joe biden is corrupt right the
joe biden has portrayed himself as this
nice elderly gentleman who is pure as
the driven snow
and that ain't true joe biden has been
spending 47 years picking up
little bennies on the side which is not
uncommon
but it is kind of gross and so by trump
did a good job of redirecting this
conversation
didn't want to tell us because he didn't
want us to panic he didn't want us
americans don't panic he panicked but
guess what in the meantime we find out
in the new york times the other day that
in fact
his folks went to wall street and said
this is a really dangerous thing
and a memo out of that meeting not from
his administration
but from some of the brokers said sell
short you're the one that takes all the
money from wall street i don't take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could raise so much more
money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
i could call the heads of wall street
the heads of every company in america
i would blow away every record but i
don't want to do that
because it puts me in a bad position and
then you bring up wall street you
shouldn't be bringing up wall street
because you're the one that takes the
money from wall street not me okay and
joe biden looking a little awkward there
because that is the fact i mean joe
biden is out raising trump on wall
street something like five to one he's
out raising him in silicon valley
like 99 to 1. so this this particular
conversation started off with joe biden
saying that he was going to take on
putin which is just absurd
on his face i mean he was part of an
administration that overtly
allowed russia to take over policy
making in syria that allowed russia to
invade crimea
he was part of an administration that
removed some of the defense capabilities
of eastern european countries
and he was the the biden obama
administration was awful with regard to
russia but here was joe biden just lying
about that because he did tell an awful
lot of lies last night
everything that's going on here about
russia is wanting to make sure
that i do not get elected the next
president united states
because they know i know them and they
know
me i don't understand why this president
is unwilling to take on putin
okay again the the trump administration
policy is significantly harsher on
russia
than anything obama ever did in just one
second we'll get to trump's
counter-attack which again was this
line which is joe biden is corrupt he's
a long-time corrupt politician
again the fact checkers are going to
have a field day with some of the claims
that trump made here because again some
of the claims that trump made here are
just not right
but the overall implication right which
that trump was trying to make here which
is that
the bidens have been trading on the
family names when rich members of the
biden family that is that is certainly
true
okay so trump had a couple of messages
first message biden is captain lockdown
he's gonna lock you down he's never
gonna let you out of lockdown second
message trump was trying to promote last
night
is that biden is a long-time corrupt
politician so he went directly after
biden as i say it is worth noting here
that some of these claims are just not
true and i think that for the sake of
honesty
we should point out that they are not
true however some of these claims
are in fact true you made three and a
half million dollars joe
and your son gave you they even have a
statement that
we have to give ten percent to the big
man you're the big man i think
i don't know maybe you're not but you're
the big man i think
your son said we have to give 10 to the
big man joe what's that all about
okay so trump is conflating a bunch of
different claims right here it is true
that hunter biden picked up three and a
half million dollars from the wife of
moscow's mayor
it is not true there's no evidence to
suggest that joe biden
benefited from that at least not
directly okay it is true
that hunter biden was picking up
enormous checks in ukraine based on the
biden family name
it is not true or at least there is no
evidence to the effect that joe biden
was picking up any of that cash it is
true that hunter biden was picking up
bags of cash in china and this is where
things have gotten a little dicey for
biden there are emails suggesting
that perhaps joe biden had something to
do with it joe biden has denied all of
that but here's the bottom line if
you're watching this debate
and this is the first time you're
hearing any of this this does change
your impression of joe biden just a
little bit
because it turns out that joe biden
actually overstated his defense
of all of this and there is something
deeply suspicious about the fact that in
american politics and it is more typical
of all politicians
than american politics you enter office
middle class or poor
and you leave office rich that is a
weird thing
but that's kind of the point is that joe
biden is a typical swamp creature and he
has been a swamp creature for a very
long time
i was put through a phony witch hunt
for three years it started
before i even got elected they spied in
my campaign
no president should ever have to go
through what i went through let me just
say this mueller an 18 angry democrats
and fbi agents all over the place spent
48 million dollars
they went through everything i had
including my tax returns
and they found absolutely no collusion
and nothing wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spend
one million on youtube i could find
plenty wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken
i mean your brother made money in iraq
millions of dollars
your other brother made a fortune and
it's all through you joe and they say
you get some of it
and you do live very well you have
houses all over the place
okay and again joe biden kind of
laughing that one off but
he is worth nine million dollars now
some of that i'm sure is book money i'm
sure a lot of that is pension
but again there are serious questions to
be asked about why it is that every
member of our public
codery goes into office poor and leaves
office rich
nothing was unethical here's what's the
deal his son
didn't have a job for a long time was
sadly no longer in
the military service i won't get into
that and he didn't have a job
as soon as he became vice president
barisma not the best look
not the best reputation in the world i
hear they paid him 183
000 a month listen to this 183
and they gave him a three million dollar
upfront payment all right and he had no
energy i'm going to let the vice
president respond to that quickly and
then i need to get to a question to you
very
no basis for that everybody investigated
that no one said anything he did was
wrong in ukraine
nobody said that anything hunter biden
did in ukraine was wrong
okay there's a difference in legally
wrong and i'm using my vp daddy's name
to
make bank and trump kept hammering this
home like over and over he kept
hammering his home and finally
biden responded and this was i thought
maybe the best moment of the night
for donald trump joe biden finally got
tired of all of this
and he pivoted to what was obviously a
pre-planned response there's only one
problem
trump absolutely walloped him over it
this is the worst moment of the debate
for biden bar none he doesn't want to
talk about the the
substantive issues it's not about his
family and my family
it's about your family and your family's
hurting badly
if you're making less than if you're a
middle-class family
you're getting hurt badly right now
that's a technical political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family
around the table everything just a
typical politician when i see that let's
talk about not a typical politician
okay that's why i got elected
okay so that is a great debate tactic
okay he just chris christie them do you
remember back in 2016 chris christie
marco rubio they're in a debate and
christie committed the world's first
political murder suicide he was already
basically done with the race and so he
just took out rubio rubio had a shot at
taking out trump in new hampshire
and christy looked at ruby and said what
you're going to say right now
is that make no mistake blah blah blah
and then rubio came back he said
make no mistake blah blah blah and
everybody went oh boom
christie called you up okay that tactic
is the most obnoxious tactic when
somebody
goes faux sincere when some when a
serious issue is being discussed
and then suddenly the candidate turns to
the camera and says
the american people don't want to hear
this the american people want to hear
about the things that affect them
for trump to call that out and be like
joe you're still full of crap i mean
honestly
you're like we're in the middle of a
conversation about family corruption and
now you're going to do the kitchen table
yeah yeah
you're a typical politician it's why i
got elected it was the best moment for
trump it was very very funny it was the
best moment for trump
all night and again highlight the fact
that
trump is not your typical politician
which in many cases is not
ideal but in this case is kind of ideal
that's kind of a good thing
okay that is not where the debate ended
and thus
we continue so the debate then turned to
foreign policy
trump was talking about north korea and
he has a good relationship with kim
jong-un
and uh and then biden started dropping
weird historical references that just
don't make any sense
they tried to meet with him he wouldn't
do it north korea
we're not in a war we have a good
relationship you know people don't
understand
having a good relationship with leaders
of other countries we have a lot of
countries we have a lot of questions to
get to know
man we had a good relationship with
hitler before he in fact
invaded europe the rest of europe come
on
come on if joe biden keeps going back to
come on that doesn't tell he's not doing
well in the debate
he was not doing well in the debate in
fact the united states did not
have a good relationship with hitler in
the lead up to world war ii
joe biden later said he was joking there
was no evidence that he was joking that
was not a joke
okay he actually the joke doesn't even
make any sense if he thinks that we had
a bad relationship
like that doesn't make any sense at all
like it just
undercuts what he's trying to say right
there then
the debate turned to health care joe
biden issued
a whopper last night of cataclysmic
proportions he said
that nobody lost their private insurance
under obamacare
this is just a lie okay in 2013 the
left-wing fact-checking site politifact
declared it was their lie of the year
when barack obama said that nobody would
lose their health insurance plan under
obamacare
and yet here is joe biden repeating it
nonetheless the idea that i want to
eliminate private insurance the reason
why i had such a fight
for with 20 candidates for the
nomination was
i support private insurance that's why i
did
not one single person with private
insurance would lose their insurance
under my plan nor did they under
obamacare
so he's lying about his own policy and
he's lying about obamacare his policy
does not merely relegate
public option to people who cannot
obtain private insurance
it allows anybody to opt into the public
option
okay this opened up the final line of
attack
for trump so there were three lines of
attack for trump last night one is that
joe biden is locked down king second is
that joe biden is corrupt
and third is that joe biden never got
anything done he's been in government
his entire life and he's never gotten
anything done
he points this out last night he was
here
before 47 years he didn't do it he was
now there as vice president for eight
years and it's not like it was 25 years
ago it was three and
three quarters it was just a little
while ago right
less than four years ago he didn't do
anything he didn't do it
he wants socialized medicine and it's
not that he wants it his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders you're going to have
socialized medicine just like you want
to with fracking
we're not going to have fracking we're
going to stop fracking we're going to
stop fracking he's talking about
destroying your medicare totally and
destroying your social security
and this whole country will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it
in his state he thinks he's running
against somebody else he's running
against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed with them
okay while i'm enjoying joe biden face
planting bernie sanders like
giving him the swirly sticking his face
in the toilet and flushing it which is
exactly what
biden's doing right there he's saying i
don't agree with bernie i don't like
medicare for all that's why i'm here and
bernie isn't
recognize that the public option is
again step one on the road towards
socialized medicine pretty much
everybody
understands that is the reality okay
then the debate turned to illegal
immigration
let me just tell you who's with their
families they built cages
you know they used to say i built the
cages and then it was determined they
were built
in 2014 that was him a lot of these kids
come out without the parents
these 500 plus kids came with
parents they separated them at the
border
who built the cages let's talk about who
built the cages
okay and that was the big question right
and joe couldn't answer it because the
fact is that it was the obama
administration that built the cages
and then biden kept going on about all
the things he was going to do with
regard to illegal immigration and trump
went back to
again that third theme which is that joe
biden has been in government forever and
never did anything about any of this
stuff
he had eight years to do what he said he
was going to do
and i've changed without having a
specific
we got rid of catch and release we got
rid of a lot of
horrible things that they put in and
that they lived with
but he had eight years he was vice
president he
did nothing except build cages
to keep children in it is true the catch
and release policy is a garbage policy
and it has released
not 11 million illegal immigrants into
the center of the country it has
released
many many more illegal immigrants
probably closer to 520 million illegal
immigrants
in the country at this point but again
trump's main point here which is that
joe biden
he keeps promising things and he's been
in the government forever he's not wrong
and again trump kept hammering this home
they turned to the issue of race and
trump
kept hammering at home right there here
is cl trump clip 38
saying that uh you know you keep talking
about how you're going to heal all the
racial wounds of the country
where have you been for the past several
decades yes i do
and again he's been in government 47
years he never
did a thing except in 1994 when he did
such harm to the black community and
they were called and he called them
super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community
than donald trump and if you look with
the exception
of abraham lincoln possible exception
but the exception of abraham lincoln
nobody has done what i've done okay
this culminated with a a very
very weak exchange for joe biden
right all of this this third line of
attack that biden's been in government
forever never done anything
this this culminated in a really
terrible moment i thought
for joe biden so here was joe biden
explaining what he's going to do now
and trump again hammers him with okay so
why didn't you do it you've been here
for
50 years why didn't you do it and
biden's answer is so stunningly and
blindingly bad that it actually stops
the debate dead
in the 80s we passed 100 percent all 100
senators voted for it
a bill on drugs and how to deal with
drugs it was a mistake
i've been trying to change the since
then particularly the portion on cocaine
that's why i've been arguing that in
fact we should not
send anyone to jail for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short time ago why didn't you do it
you just said i'm going to do that i'm
going to do this
you put tens of thousands of mostly
black young men in prison now you're
saying you're going to get
you're going to undo that why didn't you
get it done you had eight years with
obama
you know why joe because you're all talk
and no action all right vice president
biden and then we're going to move on to
the next section
we had a republican congress
that's the answer okay you got to talk
them into it you know
all right you got to talk them into it
we're going to move on to our next
section like i did with
criminal justice reform i had to talk
democrats into
gentlemen we're running out of time so
we got to get on to
climate change please okay so joe biden
stops absolutely dead
after he says we had a republican
congress no
you didn't for the first two years of
the barack obama administration
not only did democrats have a majority
in the house they had a super majority
in the senate they had a
filibuster-proof majority in the senate
okay for the first two years of the
obama administration that's how they got
obamacare done
they didn't lose the house until 2010
and they didn't lose the senate until
2014.
so it's just not true what he's saying
there is overtly untrue
okay the bottom line is that he is all
talk he doesn't do anything
trump is right about that okay the final
bad point for joe biden
happened late in the debate they're
talking about environmentalism
and biden has this very weird take that
climate change is going to kill all
humanity and so he has pledged
all of these radical policies that he
actually probably doesn't like very much
and this culminated in what was probably
the biggest boo-boo of the entire debate
and it will be in all of the campaign
ads
leading up to election day particularly
in pennsylvania
this is clip 45. so trump is hammering
him on fracking
right trump is just saying you said that
you want to ban fracking and by is like
no i said i want to ban on federal lands
he's actually said broadly speaking that
he does want to ban fracking
and then he said oh yeah by the way i
only meant federal land but there's i
mean there's tape of him saying over and
over and over again that he would like
to transition away from fracking
or ban fracking or end fracking then
he'll say well i'll just do it on
federal lands okay fine
trump gets him to admit in this clip
that he wants to end the oil industry
that he wants to destroy the entire oil
industry in the united states
that is responsible for millions and
millions of jobs
if you don't think this is going to be
an issue in pennsylvania wrong you are
here was
trump getting biden to admit that he
wishes to kill the entire oil industry
of the united states
by the way we just became energy
independent because of fracking in the
oil industry
would you close down the other way i
have a transition from the oil industry
yes
oh transition it is a big statement
because
i would stop why would you do that
because the oil industry pollutes
significantly i said here's the deal but
that's a big statement
well if you let me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
to the gas exchange to the
uh to uh solar and wind yeah why are we
giving it to oil industry we actually do
solar and wind that's maybe the biggest
statement in terms of business
that's the biggest thing okay because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you
remember that pennsylvania oklahoma vice
president biden let me give you ten
seconds to respond and then i have to
get to the final question vice president
biden
he takes everything out of context no
you literally just said it one second
ago he did not in fact take it out of
context
that was you one second ago declaring
that you were going to end the oil
industry in the united states of america
okay so no that one's on you